meanwhile the man identified by the
Obama administration as a Russian agent
walks free tonight he is a living rebuke
to this whole grotesque hoax he is
Carter Paige and he joins us live
tonight
Carter Paige thank you for coming on
thanks Raph Rito so this application
repeatedly describes you as an agent of
the Russian government repeatedly are
you aware of any criminal charges
pending against you do you expect to be
charged for working for the Russian
government not only I'm not aware of it
Tucker
there's also the fact that no question
I've ever been asked by the FBI in terms
of any of these fake theories related to
the dossier as you're alluding to none
none of those made any sense whatsoever
so there's not even a premise by which I
could even conceivably be charged so
it's absolutely it's there there are
specifics from the dossier apparently
this comes from the dossier but the
application accuses you of meeting with
two Russian officials both named Igor
Igor Sechin
and Eve Igor Divya ken did you meet with
either one of those men I never met with
them and in my life ever
yeah do you believe that that allegation
comes from the steal dossier absolutely
it's funny in July of 2016
two months before the Yahoo news article
came out I started getting these calls
from various news reporters you know
what Wall Street Journal New York Times
Washington Post CNN all asking me about
these same two names of people I've
never even heard of in my art of session
I've never even heard her to be akin and
so it was obvious you know and some
people told me from the media that they
heard about it from the Clinton campaign
etc but you know so finally they found
someone to put it out and 45 days before
the election in Yahoo News so so the
Clinton campaign of course learned about
it from Christopher Steele whom they
were paying to gather this dossier and
my understanding too from the testimony
in recent months that Steele never viz
did Russian ever bothered to go to
Russia as he assembled this dossier is
that correct that's my understanding as
well and you know there's a number of
lawsuits going on and mr. GU bar EV down
in Southern District of Florida so right
hopefully in these civil yes I know
hopefully these civil cases can get to
the bottom of this and you know it's a
great ad that this at the same time now
we learned that in October of 2016
really at the height of the intensity of
the presidential campaign Christopher
Steele on the payroll of the Clinton
campaign briefs officials at the State
Department and that briefing apparently
was used as one of the pretexts for
spying on you am i connecting those dots
correctly that's my understanding Tucker
and you know just based on this at these
four hundred plus pages of documents you
know there's a lot in there about media
you know it's sort of quoting a lot of
media sources and you know I've talked
with a couple of former assistant US
attorneys etc and no one has ever heard
of anything like this in terms of this
type of a court filing it's it's just
absolutely preposterous in terms of
their sources so one of the reasons I
find this choice so fascinating is
because you are an actual person an
American a Naval Academy graduate and
you're willing to talk in public it's
amazing to me that you have been the
target of this surveillance and and live
to tell the tale you're not being
charged as you said and I think you're
probably right
what does it done to your life how do
you feel knowing that the federal
government was spying on your personal
life for a year
Tucker it's absolutely outrageous but I
have I have to say I'm very happy to
have gotten the finally you know
fourteen months later the FBI answered
my FOIA requests this weekend we started
having a little bit of transparency
obviously there's a hundred plus pages
of blacked out information and I think
you know it's just starting the process
in terms of getting the getting to the
real truth of these crimes that were
committed against American democracy
with the
abusive process in the FISA Court so but
really committed against you I mean your
government on the basis of no actual
evidence has accused you of treason and
spied on you as a result I mean how does
that as someone who served your country
in the military as a naval officer how
does that make you feel well my bigger
concern is you know there's obviously
big problems in the US Department of
Justice there are these false court
pleadings you know the false court
pleadings that US attorney Berman has
put in in terms of Mike's civil case
against broadcasting Board of Governors
but the bigger issue which is my bigger
concern is the complete failure of the
US intelligence community in terms of
looking at this Russia issue if this is
what they're using sounds like they
sounds like they succeeded actually it's
a failure they had a very specific goal
in mind and they've achieved it that's
why we're talking about it today yeah
they've hamstrung the work the workings
of government for a year and a half
Carter page you're a lot more forgiving
than I would be in your position thank
you for joining us thanks Tucker